a brutal attack in ukraine is leading to
renewed calls for greater international
help at least 23 people were killed when
a russian missile hit close to a
residential building in a city in the
center of the country the attack is
being called deliberate holly williams
has the story and we should warn you
some of the pictures are graphic
a little girl out in the sunshine on a
summer's day
and the same girl according to a family
friend lying dead beside her stroller
killed says ukraine by a russian cruise
missile attack
the explosions came out of the bright
blue sky ukraine claims it was a
deliberate assault on civilians an
office building pummeled destroying a
medical center and damaging a nearby
residential area
we interviewed ukraine's defense
minister just hours afterwards
we had the war with the state of
terrorists to be clear you're calling
the russian military terrorists yes
absolutely i'm sure they're using their
weapon
against civilian people against the
civilian facilities against the
hospitals russia claims it was targeting
a building used by the ukrainian
military perhaps this one just across
the road which is also severely damaged
we were inside it in march interviewing
officers from the ukrainian air force
defense air defense it's their defense
but whatever the aim civilians were
slaughtered
ludmila polovic brought flowers from her
own garden this morning for the victims
he told us russia has crossed a red line
police told us this is the spot where
the little girl was killed the defense
minister didn't say whether modern air
defense systems could have prevented the
bloodshed but told us ukraine needs them
from the u.s and its
allies we want the numbers which will
cover our sky
that's it it's absolutely understandable
we need to cover our sky
the nearest front line from here is
around 200 miles away and until
yesterday this city had mainly been
peaceful since russia launched its
invasion but the reality is that very
few places are now truly safe here in
ukraine
gail
holly williams in ukraine we thank you